germany needs to lower its gas usage so
so that its reserves can be filled up by
winter says the country's economy
minister robert habeck for now germany
will ramp up electricity production at
coal power plants to make up for the
limited natural gas supply a move that
will raise carbon emissions berlin also
plans to introduce an option to
compensate companies that lower their
gas usage now this comes after russia's
gas problem announced it would be
reducing gas deliveries to germany
citing technical reasons the german
government however says the move is
politically motivated
meanwhile as europe is getting less
energy delivered from russia it's a
different situation for china where oil
imports from russia soared to a record
level on may rising 55 percent on the
year
chinese refineries are cashing in on
discounted russian oil supplies amid
western sanctions on moscow over its war
in ukraine
until last month saudi arabia was the
leading supplier to china the world's
biggest crude oil importer the latest
figures also show that
chinese oil refineries are still buying
oil from iran which has also been
targeted by western
sanctions
whereas energy supplies don't seem to be
a problem right now for china there are
issues
ramping up that could hamper
growth
throughout last year business in china
was good for eu firms with two-thirds
seeing their cells grow by at least 22
percent
but the mood shifted in april
the majority of companies lowered sales
expectations for 2022 according to the
results of a snap survey by the european
union of chamber of commerce in china
companies are worried about the
difficult geopolitical situation amid
the war in ukraine
on top of that shipping costs arising
and the closure of chinese ports due to
beijing's zero corporate strategy had a
negative impact on
business in january around 1 in 10
european firms said they wanted to move
their investments from china to other
countries
by april nearly a quarter of firms
wanted to do so
that's the highest level in a decade
and there's more chinese labor
conditions have worsened says the eu
chamber of commerce firms are
experiencing difficulty retaining
workers
all right for more let's cross over to
bettina shoeing she's the vice president
of the european
union chamber of commerce in china
welcome to dw bettina so the mood among
european companies in china is turning
increasingly sour
lockdowns supply chain strains political
pressure am i missing something
well yes um obviously you um really
listed it all so um the copied outbreak
definitely is is quite an issue and it
causes a lot of uncertainty then we have
a slowing economy and the
environment the business environment is
getting more and more political so this
makes doing business in china more and
more difficult for majority of our
members
but what exactly is the impact we don't
see an exodus of companies do we
no we don't see an exodus of companies
because the market is for sure very big
and important
but
it causes actually that headquarters
will silo they will decouple their
companies here in china they localize
the
stuff they localize id and data storage
systems and they onshore supply chains
and another effect is for sure that with
regards to future investments which
would normally have gone to china they
will
rethink it and shift it to other markets
because with this uncertainty is not a
good crown to invest
tell us about the siloing that you
mentioned
what does this mean
precisely
well yes as i have mentioned
they actually need to set up two systems
with regard to i.t and data storage
which with regards to supply chains one
for china and one for the rest of the
world and with regard to um stuffing
with positions here we see now that more
and more companies they localize
actually positions from junior staff up
to board members this leads for sure to
a decoupling because to have a diverse
team with foreigners working here in
china and also chinese going to the
headquarters this leads to more exchange
and mutual understanding and this is
crucial for doing business here one
could also argue that having more
chinese
individuals and chinese nationals in
these sort of positions of power could
be a good thing when it comes to
understanding the market
it is for sure important that also the
chinese have the opportunity to develop
and work in this position it must be a
good mix but the expats working here and
going back in the headquarters they act
as ambassadors they are multipliers
because they can report about their
experiences in the china market we
always say china is a fitness center so
you work here so you experience the
dynamics on the ground is very important
to make the headquarters understand
how china is is
working and and going
vice president of the european union
chamber of commerce in china
thank you for your time
thank you